[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
Civil War
there's gonna be a symbol there ain't
gonna be a Civil War come on
I'm gonna tell you what it is I'm gonna
tell you why they're freaking out I'm
gonna tell you why they're saying what
they're saying
because they're not just scared about
the charges the Ricoh charges that were
put against Donald Trump and his allies
for trying to overturn the Georgia
election and elections in other states
they're terrified that they won't be
able to rile up another January 6th
that's what they're scared of they're
terrified of it they're terrified that
their influence
to to stoke stochastic terrorism is over
we watched it we watched it I mean even
even Tom Cotton On Hugh Hewitt Show
today was talking about how they were
upset that it is it's
oh the Fulton D.A is so incompetent that
it took him till before midnight to do a
press conference what are you talking
about they stayed up all night to do the
press conference you stupid [__]
they're really upset they're really
upset that Trump supporters
are not being violent
that's what they're truly upset about
here
and they're terrified of it
they're terrified that Trump supporters
aren't being violent but it's not it's
not hard to know why they're not being
violent there there are Trump supporters
right now who went to the Capitol on
January 6 to overturn our government to
Crown Donald Trump King as an
insurrectionist with violence with their
bare feet on a prison floor right now as
we speak
you know we've we've listened to a lot
of folks out there in the country say oh
we need to hold them accountable get rid
of Merrick Garland America Aaron's not
home
they're not doing well
after Justice
well I'll tell you that there wasn't
anyone who showed up in Georgia and I
don't I don't know if you know about the
state of Georgia but in the state of
Georgia there's plenty of people who
support Donald Trump delusionally that
could have showed up at the courthouse
that day
when there was 41 charges dropped on
Trump and 18 of his co-conspirators
in a RICO case
and they didn't
they didn't show
and that's that's why Tim Poole and all
the other right-wing talkers are losing
their minds they're trying they're
damnedest they're trying their [__]
damnedest
to get these people to commit violence
civil war Civil War civil oh there's
still work coming hey man there's still
work coming
have you ever talked to one of these
idiots like seriously like belly to
belly talk to him when they're like oh
there's there's gonna be a Civil War and
you just ask him the question like who
is fighting in the Civil War who is
fighting Republicans and Democrats
so you're saying that like we're gonna
put on red shirts and blue shirts and
we're gonna have boxing matches I don't
know what you're talking about are you
saying that that Republicans are gonna
commit terrorism because that seems like
what you're saying against the state
right
that's a Civil War I don't I don't know
if these [__] have done any
studying of what our former Civil War
was
but the former Civil War was what
Marjorie Taylor green would like to call
a national divorce even though she's
going through a real divorce
because she's you know believes in the
sanctity of marriage or something I
don't know
but our last Civil War it was
Traders
who were fighting our nation
and the military of our nation
now
fast forward
to the 2023 Civil War that they want so
badly
you don't want to see you [__] idiots
sit down you don't want a civil war
trust me after what I'm about to tell
you
see you don't you don't have drones okay
yeah you got you got cool AR-15s that
you like to try to scare people with and
you like to act like you're a domestic
terrorist and your Christmas card
pictures I get it I get it you think you
look cool oh I yeah it's all over the
place if you're a republican you have to
take the stupid [__] picture With the
flak jacket with an America upside down
American flag and an AR-15 with your
[__] shades on
they're all over social media do you
remember when the [__] Chinese
balloon
was over the United States every single
one of them were pointing their guns
outside to the sky like they were gonna
shoot down a [__] balloon listen it's
lunacy
it doesn't make any sense it's the way
that they're they're [__] coping
but honestly people like Tim Poole they
had influence Charlie Kirk Tim Poole
Jesus Christ Donald Trump he tweeted
remember it's gonna be wild to come to
January 6th it's gonna be wild I know
it's gonna be because a bunch of [__]
toothless idiots are going to show up
and commit violence for me
hell he told them don't don't don't let
the mags be on turn the [__] mags off
let the weapons through they're not
going to use them on me they're going to
use them on them
you really want a civil war Tim come on
man
you're listen Tim you're a dumb [__]
okay I I understand that you're you're a
little [__] stupid dumbass audience
who doesn't have a handful of brain
cells to rub together between a lot of
them
but God damn man really Civil War are
you serious come on
you talking about number one there's not
gonna be a civil war because if there is
a civil war you will lose immediately
immediately you will lose
I don't know if you I don't know if you
were paying attention to January 6 but
the one thing that is significant about
January 6 and that you know a lot of
folks on the right are pissed off about
is that they reconvene that night and
did their government business
they certified the election
that night
just like Tom Cotton's pissed off that
Bonnie Willis which she it almost took
her till midnight to do press conference
it shows commitment
it shows dedication it shows I don't
know like loyalty to an oath
you people aren't loyal at all you
understand that right you manga idiots
you moglodytes out there you're not
loyal at all you're not Patriots you're
you're you're [__] traitors you
dummies
you being with Trump is being against
America
and you're when you're calling for civil
war you're calling for civil war against
our country and our nation
you're the [__] terrorist
so not only do you look dumb because
there isn't going to be no Civil War
you [__] little [__] there's not
going to be a civil war but not only
that you look like the baddies man I
mean you are but you look like the
baddies when you're saying it like
you're saying it why you're saying it
oh I don't like I don't like that our
guy our Mussolini Jesus
is being prosecuted for trying to
overturn free and fair elections
we shouldn't have to be prosecuted we
hate democracy we [__] hate democracy
so much so that we'll fight democracy
this democracy will kill the government
we'll fight them get the [__] out of
here listen to what you're saying you
dumb [__]
it's ridiculous
just on its face I'm telling you if you
ever get again if you get in front of
one of these idiots that are like yeah
I'm going to be part of the Civil War
like uh what's his name Craig Robertson
how'd that work out how'd that civil
work work out for you Craig
oh man that Civil War worked real good
didn't it oh man oh [__] Craig did Craig
did a lot he made a lot of inroads into
that Civil War
the Battle of dumb [__] out in Utah
stupid [__]
what do you think is gonna happen huh
honestly honestly I can't wait for them
to keep going here and it keeps saying
the stupid [__]
about Civil War and how the country's
gonna [__]
you know we're gonna take back our
[__] country and that sort of stupid
[__] good do it go for it no one's
showing up for you
no one is showing up for you
I mean yeah you get your [__] little
Nazi right-wing keyboard Cowboys in the
comment section is that what you're
talking about Tim we're gonna have a
civil war in the comment section get the
[__] out of here
that's the only civil war that you got
really
is the Civil War on information
now that's a civil war we can actually
talk about right
that's a real Civil War that's going on
in this country the the war on
misinformation and information in
general
it's happening [__] I'm on the front
line
I'm trying to get I'm trying to get my
group together
so that we can fight misinformation
but they can't stop [__] up either
[__] up the national narrative
running around
not being on the correct Battlefield
over here in all of the battlefield
that's not it you're it's not even a
fight over there on the that Battlefield
that's the Civil War we're fighting
it's the war of information the war of
the truth to be quite honest with you if
you wanna if you wanna know
what it truly is
it's the Civil War of the truth
and Temple would know the truth if it
sat on his [__] bald head
that's right I'll shame him I don't give
a [__] you know me I don't care I don't
give a [__] people are mad yet some
people were mad yesterday that I was
making fun of Jeff I don't spell my
first name right Duncan and the four
lieutenant governor of Georgia so if you
were a little upset I don't know what to
tell you I'm gonna make fun of these
people I'm gonna mock them and I'm gonna
take any opportunity that I can oh Tony
why would you do that yeah well they're
easy to be mocked so what are you gonna
do and this is the best weapon against
them
when when they're when they're on
Twitter saying [__] like Civil War yes
mock them
shame them that's what you should be
doing all day every day all of them in
the comments
I mean have you have you seen did you
did you see
Craig Robertson
you know what I'm talking about right I
I know I know this feels like a thousand
years ago but this was last week
this is the guy who threatened to
assassinate President Biden and the
Manhattan D.A
he was going to assassinate Biden when
he came to Utah
and he was very specific about what
rifle he was going to use even in his
Facebook post the FBI went to serve a
search warrant
dude get dude get trigger happy thought
thought he was in the Civil War but Tim
Poole was talking about and got his
[__] ass killed
suicide by cop
because Civil War what the [__]
the hell out of here with that nonsense
but this is this is what Tim Poole and
the right wing Talking Heads won they
know they're not they they know listen
they know they know they're not gonna
get
a band of idiots to do another January
6th right they're just not gonna do it
there's no way you're gonna commence a
group of people after they watch what
happened on January 6 and watch what
happened to the people on on that went
to January 6.
prison time prison sentence after prison
sentence after prison sentence there's
no way you're going to get a a group
gathered up like that again it's just
not gonna happen
it's not I hate to break it to you
especially to go against the United
States military what get the [__] out of
here
but what they want what they want is
Lone actors
they want solos stochastic terrorism
they're trying to drum up someone
creating some sort of event
that can hurt somebody like like the
[__] the crazy Hammer guy
in San Francisco at the Pelosi residence
right Craig Robertson the guy that
walked into the Cincinnati FBI with the
nail gun you remember this [__]
it's the kind of stuff they want that's
what they want that's that's what
they're trying to do
yeah hey Tim yeah send me a cease and
desist [__]
let's go to court let's let's go to
Discovery I'd I'd love to see your
internal Communications about what
you're saying about Civil War to your
producers and people around you I'd love
to see it
because that's what Tim Poole and the
right wing Talking Heads are doing
is intentionally intentionally
trying to cause some sort of terrorism
stochastically oh well well oh my God if
you're going to do this to Trump then
imagine what we'll do the Democrats wink
wink hey my nut bag followers wink wink
we know what you're doing man I see what
you're doing Baldy you bald-headed [__]
I had my hat on today
um
in solidarity of Temple covering up his
bald ass head I I you know I have hair I
[__] get my hair out every day
but it is hat week a lot of people like
the hemp this morning in the comments so
if you want to [__] them hat go to go to
hats.dtonymichaels.com that's hats not
the Tony michaels.com you can use a
promo code this week to get 10 off your
hat order
ten percent off your hat order
use the promo code hat week now hat week
now because right now it is hat week hat
week now you use it when you go to
stats.thetonymichaels.com or you can go
to thetonymichaels.com click on the hat
store link there the [__] them hat link
and you it'll get you there and again
use the promo code hat week now to get
10 off your [__] hats like I'm
wearing right here in solidarity with 10
pool
I'm bald and I'm impotent and I'm I'm
such a [__] idiot so I'm gonna type
in Civil War at least 100 times on the
Twitter machine because I couldn't get
out of my studio to do [__] so I gotta
get people to do it for me just like you
did on January 6 Tim
we know what you did we seen what you
did we see what you're continuing to do
and it's not just Temple it's Ben
Shapiro it's Charlie Kirk it's Penny
Johnson it's all these [__] idiots
out there saying it's even congressmen
and Senators saying well look you know
what's gonna happen now now that they're
coming at the Republicans we're gonna
come after Democrats go for it you
[__] idiots go for it get your
prosecutors in your DA's go get your
budgets together and go prosecute some
Democrats do it
do it
stop [__] talking about it and do it
that's what we did
we elected we elected we the people
elected prosecutors to prosecute your
[__] crimes Republicans that's right
we the people elected prosecutors to get
their [__] asses out there and go
process prosecute some goddamn crime
and that's what the [__] they're doing
in four jurisdictions right now against
their Mussolini Jesus
so yeah that's how it works if you wanna
if you want Law and Order and you want
people to prosecute crimes just go to
The Ballot Box elect the right
[__] and smart smart
prosecutors which are normally [__]
Democrats let's face it there's not many
[__] Republican prosecutors that are
[__] that decent I mean what do you
want from me Durham Durham totally
[__] it up right am I right look at
that prosecutor totally [__] it up
David Weiss on the hunter Biden case he
was like yeah I'll just be the United
States Attorney uh with Trump and then
he couldn't get anything else in court
besides [__] Hunter messed up on his
taxes and he was he was had he had a gun
when he was doing drugs which is a dumb
ass [__] charge anyways that's a
stupid [__] charge so is charging
someone with with misdemeanors for uh
tax errors when they paid the taxes that
the errors were in get the [__] out of
why are we wasting our time with this
[__]
huh why this is like [__] arresting
people for a bag of weed get the [__]
out of here this is nonsense
we got people down in Georgia people in
Washington DC Arizona Michigan Wisconsin
trying to overturn an election
and where and we're worried about what
what one dude who's not in the
government
may have made an error on his taxes
intentional or unintentional and then he
paid the taxes that he owed and we're
worried about that [__] that's
what we're because he's got a huge dick
and you're jealous of it what
the [__] out of here
but this is the Republican way they
don't understand democracy because they
don't believe in it
they don't believe in democracy
they don't believe that what we should
do is elect prosecutors and by our
choices being made for what prosecutors
we select
didn't they go prosecute the crimes
because we put them in charge of
Prosecuting crimes they don't understand
that's how [__] democracy Works they
don't get it they don't get it and they
also clearly don't understand that when
you commit crime in a jurisdiction
you're going to be prosecuted in that
particular jurisdiction they don't
understand that at all I don't get how
the F well how in the [__] Jesus Christ
I thought I thought at this point in our
country's history with all the [__]
crime dramas we think about this think
about all not just the [__] fictional
ones but the non-fictional murder
documentaries that we have nowadays at
our fingertips think about this think
about all the information that we have
at our fingertips of of a culture that
is steeped steeped in how [__]
prosecutions somewhat work whether it's
fake or it's real right
oh talking about fake and real
prosecutions and how they work and how
they don't oh my God man
the [__] illegal analysis on on these
cases is all over the map and it feels
like I'm gonna be honest it feel it
feels like to me like when I watch
when I watch MSNBC I don't know you can
ah you can take me for this I don't care
when I'm watching MSNBC every once in a
while
uh because I just I gotta see what the
hell they're saying right they're like
five months behind me
it's hilarious it's hilarious I heard
David Jolly I heard David jolly and he's
he might have been saying this for some
time I don't know if you know David
Jolly is he's a former Republican
congressman from from Florida he's a
never Trumper right and David Jolly on
MSNBC this morning is like well it looks
like Trump's got it cinched up I don't
think there's any way anyone else is
going to win this nomination
hey David Man David listen if you if you
want to be I know right now you're like
five months behind me but if you want to
catch up just give me a phone call Buddy
well we'll have a conversation I'll get
you right there man I'll get you right
where you need to be
I'll get you right and I I you know I
it's not I'm not saying I don't like
David Jolly that's not what I'm saying
it just you you [__] have been
you [__] have been sick of
fanting and simping for the wrong [__]
okay you're not paying attention to
what's happening these these [__]
Talking Heads and I've been telling you
I've been telling the audience that I
know a lot of people don't like when I
say that [__] and they don't like when I
go there why are you attacking them
because it it the [__] is at stake
our national narrative is at stake
don't you get it
I'm telling you they're knocking on our
front [__] door and they're not going
away the fascists are not gonna go away
anytime soon
and having some kind of false [__]
hope on [__] that isn't gonna happen
folks that is dangerous as [__]
we have to get [__] real like real
quick
and I'm I'm glad to see David Jolly's
finally caught up
I'm glad to see that MSNBC and some of
these Talking Heads are finally caught
up Jesus Christ I I listened to uh was
it yesterday I don't forget I forget who
it was I forget who it was and they were
talking about [__] cameras in the
courtroom again and and they were saying
well it looks like we'll get cameras in
Georgia but we're not going to get
cameras in the federal court and no [__]
Sherlock
why do you think Mark Meadows is one of
the first to get is trying to take this
to a federal courtroom
I don't know I don't know Mark Meadows
will be successful in this attempt to
lift the the prosecution from a Georgia
courtroom to a federal courtroom but
it's possible
it's possible I think Mark Meadows wants
to do that so there's not any cameras
inside his trial
because he's definitely made some deal
with the feds for sure
I don't I don't know we'll see
again you don't know these things until
they happen you don't know these rulings
and these motions until they happen
and when you're when you're listening to
people who are saying this is how it's
gonna be and it's gonna be this way no
matter what
on the legal part of it in the courtroom
you're you're not paying attention
you're not these people are gonna take
deals okay they're gonna take deals
there's not gonna be 19 people in court
in Georgia
they're not
there's gonna be a hand handfuls of them
that take deals and it's going to take a
while because not only when they take a
deal now now they have to readjust their
case
based on what evidence that person turns
and what testimony that person turns
it's gonna take a while
it's gonna take more than the six months
that Bonnie Willis is saying she wants
to get to I mean yeah she's setting the
bar but that's the point
and she's not tricking you she's not
trying to [__] you she just like
look if I could have this trial in six
months that's how quick I want to have
it
but be honest with yourself
be real with yourself don't lie to yours
it's not worth lying to yourself right
that's not worth it
and that's what happens a lot of times
in this stupid [__] someone says Jenna I
think Jenna Ellis is mayflip oh Jen
Ellis is gonna flip 100 percent you know
how I know this Jenna Ellis is a
DeSantis supporter and it's not because
she likes DeSantis
I'm just saying I'm just saying
I'm just saying
and all this is gonna play out in front
of our eyes but the one thing we have to
keep focused on
the one thing we have to keep focused on
is National narrative and that's that's
what these right Wingers are trying to
do
okay and that's what they're best at
there's so much the right wing is so
much better at National narrative than
the left ever [__] dreams of
they just are they are
they they are
they're just better at it
don't believe me look when they got
Donald Trump
and they've got plenty of delusional
people in their Republican Trump cult
that believe every [__] word he says
every [__] last word of it
and it's because they're better at
messaging right
but the problem is is when you message
with lies it haunts you
it haunts you and it eventually comes
crumbling down I don't know if you've
heard of what happened in Europe in the
1930s and the 1940s you know rounds
about Germany or so right in that area
and I don't know if you I don't know if
you read the books on what happened then
but if you did then you know what I'm
talking about
so all we have to do
We the People the pro-democracy
Coalition have to get really good really
good at narrating the truth
that's what we have to get good at
really good at narrating the truth and
we have to aim our strategic outrage in
that specific way
that's that's how we do it
that's how that's how we did it if you
watch that's how we did it in 2020 and
2022 it was close
and it was a patchwork of that National
narrative for the truth
but we got there
I mean you know and we got there we
can't let up our guard now and we can't
be focused on dumb stupid [__] right but
the one thing we have to focus on is
rebutting their narrative and the way we
do that is not combating their
narratives creating our own
it's creating our own narrative
but they're at our front door so it's
it's difficult because we're trying to
hold the doors shut right and get them
off at the porch at the same time
it's a really tough situation
but we have to stay vigilant and we have
to stay focused because we are Trump's
jury it is us we are all these
Republicans jury and boy do I have some
videos to show you today oh they're
crying
Marjorie Taylor green she wishes she
wishes fonnie Willis would just
prosecute rapists
who's going to tell her who's gonna
who's gonna tell her who's gonna tell
her that the guy on the head of the RICO
charges is a [__] rapist who's gonna
tell her I don't hey I don't don't come
at me the Eugene Carroll case confirms
it he's a [__] rapist and Bonnie
Willis is technically Prosecuting him
not for rape but you know maybe raping
our democracy maybe that's what you'd
say you know grabbing our democracy by
the [__] just assaulting it you know
what I mean
he's good at that he's good at that if
you if you can't wait to see these
videos hit the Subscribe button right
now I'm trying to get better at this
YouTube thing hit the like button down
below
hit the I mean it's over here hit the
like button right right there
I don't know
go ahead and subscribe it's free like
while you're here
spread the spread the spread the wealth
around send the uh the link to the video
to your family and your friends even if
they're trumpers and if you want to get
a comment on the show today if you want
to see the comment right they have a
question or you just want to tell me
that you love me or tell me that you
hate me go ahead and go to the venmo
chat the links down below you can send
me a message I'll bring it up on the air
you send that venmo chat
to the Tony Michaels on venmo don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
blankets now at
store.imgames.com that's right huge and
own yourself
might might need to when you run across
Mark Meadows or Rudy Giuliani or Trump
for that matter
if you want a throwing
um pardon blankets at him the next rally
next Nazi rally throw pardon blankets at
him so just go to store.im games
dot to come and get your pardon blanket
they exist they're real they're real now
over on the over on his merch store you
go to the Tony michaels.com too and find
the Gabe Sanchez merch link there
the merch store for Gabe Sanchez where
you can find your own very own pardon
blanket oh and don't forget if you like
the [__] em hat we got a lot of
different designs at hats.d Tony
michaels.com that's michaels.com it's
hat week hat week hat week and you get
10 off if you use the promo code hat
week now that's hat week now
when you're checking out and buying your
[__] hats
they're Lively over there
so if you like the Hat I'll tell you
what yesterday
um you know this Discord is popping off
they got tons of right now on the live
show chat they're just posting gifts and
talking [__] talking [__] over there on
Discord but if you want a place where
the chat party never stops with the chat
putting Nava steps go over to the
Discord let me let me put the link in
the chat here so you have it here that
way you got it so you got the the link
that always helps it seems like that's
what you want to do anyways let's go
over to the Discord we got there's a lot
of people starting to Pile in there you
know what I mean
and they're talking right now
yeah see Rico says [__] them Tony right
there in the in the live chat so if you
guys want to get in on the chat over on
Discord and you want to continue the
shows chat after the Discord because
it's not just about the show it's it's
about uh politics and
it's basically has The Rock and Roll
Tattoo attitude that the show has right
over there and this is a community that
they're building over there and I say
they because you know it's got the
podcast name on it but it's it's the
[__] fan over there so if you guys
want to get in on the action and go to
Discord
go to the uh go to the the Discord
server and have a party over there and
we did we did they they were showing I
was in the uh one of the rooms where
they were streaming and John Oliver
episode on Rudy Giuliani yesterday oh my
God so hilarious
so hilarious uh and this has been a
while ago this uh John Oliver episode
that did on rude Giuliani but oh my God
it totally describes him and they and
they they've been playing other
documentaries and I think we're going to
do other documentaries over there too
you know I've told you about the
documentary Hitler a career maybe we'll
watch that one over there see if we can
see any parallels together to uh to that
time and this time
apparently uh Tim Poole Tim Pooh won
civil war
and then all these other [__]
crybabies are you drowning in marketeers
yet are you drowning marketeers uh
here's a look speaking of uh manga tears
there's no one that cries War maggotiers
than Mike Lindell holy [__] we talked
about him yesterday and we we said that
there was going to be some kind of um
[__] Symposium oh no cyber Symposium or
some [__] he's gonna he's gonna he's
gonna have some sort of evidence now
it's been two and a half years he hadn't
had any evidence yet he hadn't been able
to provide us how Dominion stole the
election or some [__] whatever Hugo
Chavez was up to in his grave and the
Jewish space lasers along with the
Italians I don't know we we try to go
through this tinfoil I had [__]
yesterday
what what do you want from me what do
you want from me
I I don't I can't I can't figure out
what the hell they're talking about
some dumb [__] that they got going on
but here's here's Mike Lindell speaking
on dumb [__] here's Mike Lindell and I
think I believe this is this morning or
yesterday I'm not really sure which but
this is on um his uh his TV station his
Trader TV News Network that he's got
going but this is down in my state
Springfield Missouri I know Springfield
Missouri pretty well I'm not sure
exactly what Auditorium they're in you
guys think I should go down there
and uh just interrupt Mike Lindell and
see what we can get going on but here's
here's uh here's Mike Lindell at this uh
election cyber symbol I don't know let's
listen and you never gave up instead of
getting attacked
hacked and attack
you knew
we get this one chance or we lose the
American dream forever
and that's it we lose our country there
is a bright side to all this though hey
if we're wrong it's the end it's it's in
times we all us Believers go to heaven
it's you know it's a win-win right no
what is he is he saying is he saying
because because Trump wasn't elected
it's end times
is that what he's saying oh this guy
this guy in the [__] he's got for brains
is something else isn't it
well I I a lot of the chat doesn't know
what the hell he's talking about folks
this is listen to me listen to me
because someone asked me in the Discord
chat yesterday I believe it was Discord
jet I think that's where they were
asking me they're like what what's gonna
happen on Monday when Trump comes out
and and gives his evidence or whatever
the [__] he's whatever the [__] he's
talking about
this is the guy he's getting it from the
video I just showed you the my pillow
Nazi Mike Lindell the crackhead
him this is the guy that Trump's gonna
get this evidence from that's gonna
exonerate him
I'm excited about it to be quite honest
oh my God who the [__] wouldn't be
excited about Donald Trump trying to
decode what Mike lindell's talking about
on national TV in front of a microphone
that's what I want to do that every day
every day listen I would be willing I
would be willing to say that what we
should do is every day three times a day
give Trump 45 minutes
ever I'm telling you this is gonna work
every day let him cut in on TV on radio
and just let him talk his nonsense
it sounds like oh my God that would be
horrible Tony it would be horrible it
would be a disaster for him
because the country would get so [__]
sick and tired of the lies and the
nonsense and the [__] that that they
would overwhelmingly go reject their
asses and I mean they I mean anyone who
supported Trump
from from presidential ticket all the
way down to county commissioner and dog
catcher
they would get so [__] sick of his
ass why do you think he lost in 2020 you
realize the one reason why Trump lost in
2020 is because he wouldn't stop getting
in front of a microphone
like that's literally every everyone was
paying attention we're all sitting at
[__] home you know you're all sitting
at [__] home during coven you're
watching the [__] TV you're watching
social media that's all you're [__]
doing and all you're doing is seeing
videos of the president United States
Donald Trump talking some dumb ass [__]
and what happened
what happened eight million [__]
people that's what happened eight
million more people went and said [__]
that guy think about this in 2016
Hillary Clinton had three million more
votes than Trump
in 2016. and the turnout you know wasn't
the best in the world
but the turnout was really [__] high
in 2020
and Joe Biden smoked Trump almost three
times more than what Hillary did smoked
him
from a basement of all places during
covet Biden wasn't holding rallies they
weren't really doing huge events they
were doing big digital events online
but people are like [__] this guy [__]
this guy talking this crazy ass [__]
every day when we're locked down people
are getting sick people are [__]
dying around us
this [__] is talking about
drinking bleaching and getting the
sunshine inside your body
what the [__] talking about horse
dewormer
and hydro clock secoroquine or whatever
the [__] fish tank cleaner what the [__]
people said sick of that [__]
trust me when I say this on Monday oh my
God that video that's gonna that they're
gonna put out I hope every [__] cable
news agency I hope every goddamn new
agency in the [__] world Cuts in to
let the world see how dumb that son of a
[__] is
it ain't gonna go well
it ain't
it's gonna go over like a wet fart in a
white thong
that's what it'll be on Monday and I
can't wait for it I can't wait and it's
supposed to happen before the show
now he'll probably be late so he'll
probably be doing it during the show
maybe I'll broadcast him live here I
doubt it
we always get to talk about it you know
what I mean
we always get to talk about it here in a
real way we don't have to we don't we
don't have to air it live and show it to
you I mean the point is is what we want
to do is break down the [__] that's
important and tell you why it's
important for the narrative
it's a weekend
mm-hmm
[__] Mike Lindell
keep going buddy
I wonder how much I wonder how much cash
he spent on this uh cyber Symposium down
in Springfield Missouri
if you know anything about Springfield
Missouri if you know anything about
Springfield Missouri it is not like
the heartbeat
of culture in our country it's not right
have you guys been uh uh Springfield
Missouri is like one big white Suburbia
like the whole thing right it's it's the
third it's the third largest
City in Missouri a lot of people in
Colombia's but Springfield's bigger than
Missouri and one reason why is because
Springfield is on I-44
and I-44 is the the artery out to the
West in Missouri
the Lower West
the southwest and and I-44 it because
it's fixated right on I-44 it's a huge
Trucking Hub
huge Trucking Hub and anytime there's a
huge Trucking Hub there's a lot of drug
trafficking right a ton of drug
trafficking and I don't know if you know
that in this country but there's all
those all those big semi trucks that you
see on the highways running here and
there and they're they're carrying
actual legitimate loads they got
illegitimate loads in those trucks too
not all of them Jesus Christ but a lot
of them
if you ever met someone who owns a
trucking company
more than likely
they've carried some drugs in their
trucks before
I don't yeah you [__] come at me all you
want
come at me all you [__] want
that's just the [__] truth and if you
don't know that
I'm just telling you something you don't
know now go go do a little bit of
research
on it there's a ton of drugs that's how
drugs get transported from one state to
the next
especially in like a grain trucks and
Seed tricks
you ever seen these
at grain and seat tricks
it's it's what they you know you know
they're hauling oats and wheat
and all kinds of produce and these big
huge trucks and they they put drugs down
in the produce because they're not gonna
go through the whole thing
right that's where they traffic drugs
it happens it's a real thing anyways the
point is is that that's the kind of [__]
you get at Springfield Missouri but see
in Springfield it's so close to Branson
right and you're you're really in
Arkansas at that point when you get down
to Branson you can spit on Arkansas
do you guys know about Brands Missouri
you guys know about Brandon Missouri
Branson Missouri is the the
entertainment capital of the world
and really it's it's really kind of
weird
and the reason why is because it's a
really really the stench of Christian
fascism right with this white Christian
nationalism oh man why I'm well down in
Branson Missouri they sing about it all
the time literally the whole Show's you
know like around it they're you know
they love the live Confederate flag down
there and all kind of crazy [__] because
they're really close to Arkansas and
they're really close to Harrison
Arkansas
and if you guys know anything about
racism and the KKK in this country you
know about Harrison Arkansas and we
talked about it on the show before
but but Branson is like the the sister
city of Harrison Arkansas and Branson
kind of sets the tone for Springfield
Missouri it's kind of all in that same
little part of the
part of the butthole of the country
right
but what I'm telling you is that's why
Mike Glendale is having
that's why Mike Lindell is having this
down there
sound sound is something wrong with my
sound
what's going on with my sound my audio
is glitchy
is that better
I hope it's better if not I'm gonna have
to go to a break and figure something
else out how is the audio now
see I never can tell I've got it on my
end but see when we broadcast through
the internet
it's cranking okay all right let's go to
a break when I come back maybe I'll have
my maybe I'll have my microphone fixed
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from fighting
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these true
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
foreign
I don't know they're saying on the
commercial that it was crackling too
it might be
um it might be uh it might be just on
YouTube I don't know if it's on Twitch
or not I don't knows speaking of twitch
you should follow us on Twitch just in
case we have audio issues on [__] the
tubes of you
um
if it's the tubes of you and just go to
twitch.tv slash the Tony Michaels you
can follow us over there for free
it's 3.99 to follow us over there and
you can subscribe for free as well
here's how you do it if you have a Prime
account an Amazon Prime account you can
use your Amazon Prime account you can
tie it to your Twitch account you get
one free subscription one free
subscription
and you can get commercial free viewing
and it gives us a couple dollars of
Amazon's money
so if you've got an Amazon Prime account
link it to your Twitch account at
twitch.tv slash D Tony Michaels and then
we get a couple bucks and you get
commercial free view in case my mic
messes up on YouTube it sounds like
there's something with the connection
with YouTube I don't know
can anyone on Twitch tell me if it's a
if it's working over there
if it's if it sounds if it sounds decent
and and people are saying it's okay now
sounds good now okay well fine [__] you
then
all right I have my other microphone
here hooked up just in case Justin's
case [__] goes awry that's what I was
doing on the break now Gabe Sanchez is
gonna join us here in about 10 minutes
we're gonna watch his new what was that
that's right we're gonna watch the new
what was that I don't know which one I
don't know if it's today's the last one
but we're gonna watch one of them we're
gonna watch it what was that I know you
guys love what was that
it's a great piece of content
like Gabe Sanchez done he's come a long
way with this piece of content I don't
know if you guys know we should be very
very lucky and very proud of of my
co-host and our executive producer here
uh of this piece of content it is
fantastic and if you want to support
Gabe Sanchez in his effort of continuing
to make that pizza content do that for
me because really honestly I think I
think what was that could be a bigger
show than this podcast I think so don't
you think so I think it could be I think
it could be on a goddamn Network
somewhere
every single day 30 minutes a day
he works really hard on it he does a
great job too with the graphics and he's
really tried to you know hone in his
skills
um for this originally originally he he
came to me and Gabe Sanchez I'll tell
you the story before he comes on you
know so he's not all embarrassed while
he's here
but Gabe Sanchez came to him and he
wanted to do a piece of content that was
like a late night TV show kind of style
I'm like okay he's like kind of like
Seth Meyers or Daily Show and
and when we thought about it a lot we
went back and forth he did a lot of
working of how it would look
and we we tossed around the name and he
finally he finally landed on this one he
liked this one I'm not sure if it was uh
which one of us really came up with the
exact thing but the whole what was that
because you know there were Republicans
are stupid
right she's like well they see a lot of
[__] that you're just like what the [__]
how do you even believe that [__] so
that's kind of where it came from right
and he started off doing these what was
that and he was he was posting him on
the minus touch Network we were playing
him on the show here too
um but then it got to where it was so
much work involved in these right and
these small little pieces that he had to
figure out a way to do more of them and
and have it be just as good of content
because he had so many stories that he
wanted to do right like it's every
[__] day there's just like this
waterfall
of stories that could be in the what was
that I mean he misses so many like he's
probably got dozens that he that he half
wrote that he had to skip to another one
that's how quick it was so that's why I
ask you to support him uh in in his
content of what was that because it's
it's his piece of content it is his he
does it on his channel he puts some of
them on Midas Touch network but he does
it for you he does it for you because he
loves to make content in this way I
don't know if you know this but he would
much rather do the one was that then
come on the show
I'm telling you he would and the reason
why is because he likes those details if
you know anything about game changes he
likes all those little details right he
likes those Easter eggs he likes those
little Clips he likes to make the jokes
you know he likes to have him perfect
too
sometimes he'll send me something and
he'll send me two different things and
I'm he's like which one do you like I'm
like what the [__] is the difference and
he has to point out what the difference
is sometimes because it's so it's such a
small detail but he's so he's so focused
in on those details
which is good that's why that's why that
piece of content
is so incredible so you should support
him so go to patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez or what you can do is go to what
was that
show.com that's what was that show.com
it'll take you directly to the patreon
page
what was that show.com it'll take you
directly to the patreon page and support
him there that that's how he does that
content is you all supporting that's how
we do this content
we're independent right I don't a lot of
people think like uh some Super PAC pays
me to do this I do not get paid but I've
never taken a dime with Super PAC money
I've never taken a Super PAC payment
ever
ever I've not taken a Super PAC payment
I know that people like well but you're
on mine is touch yeah but there's two
things there they gotta pack and then
they got the the media Network
I've never taken any super bag money
ever
and I probably never will I don't know
that anyone I don't know if there's a
pack out there that would actually pay
me to be quite honest with you and if
there is if there is a pack out there
that would pay me to do this hey man
come on
and I'm still waiting on the Sorrows
check too
right so we're independent we don't
there's no one telling us what to do
here no trust me no I've had a few
people try to tell me what to do
and it didn't work out so well for them
because I I'm not gonna do what you want
me to do I'm gonna do it how I want to
do it
that's why I'm independent
and because we're independent we're
making our own way and you are our way
of support
and we wouldn't be here without you
without the audience without everyone
engaging without the people on Discord
without the folks over on Twitch without
all of you in the [__] fam chat on
the up wires chat on Facebook
or even even if you're still out there
on Twitter posting comments underneath
the show like I can see it because I
can't I hate to tell you that that's why
no one watches on Twitter because I'm
like don't watch on Twitter
just click the YouTube link above the
tweet and then and then come listen if
you want to engage all the people who
who have sent uh messages in the tip jar
every single one of the patreon members
um you guys are our backbone you are the
reason why we stay in this this is the
reason why we turn on our microphone
every day
because of you
you know you know I don't have big
[__] corporate sponsors giving me all
kinds of AD money maybe one of these
days
when someone when someone finally
figures out that you guys are that you
guys are honed in
on political talk
and that this is a good place to
advertise to put their products in front
of you we'll probably we probably will
have to turn away most people right
we'll probably have to turn them away
advertisers that is
but at this point they haven't figured
that out yet because you are one of the
most engaged audience I don't know if
you knew this but that I think last
month I believe the report was last
month when I looked it up
you guys watched almost 6 million
minutes of this show 6 million minutes
that's a lot especially for the small
channel that that's just on the one
YouTube Channel That's not including
twitch That's not including up wire
That's not including how much you watch
on Facebook that's just the one YouTube
channel
you guys you guys know exactly what you
want
and you're engaged and I appreciate that
even yesterday when um Jeff was a little
upset in the chat because I was making
fun of Jeff Duncan
he's engaged man because you guys aren't
you guys definitely are not afraid to
tell me what you think and I I
appreciate that that's what I want I
want people in our audience that aren't
[__] afraid to say what the [__] they
want
and how they want to say it and what
they want to say even if it comes after
me I'm fine with that
I'm okay with that I got a thick skin
you know that
you're not gonna scare me off the
microphone not one bit
but that's what makes us truly
independent here at the Tony Michaels
podcast it's what truly makes
Independent Media you guys know a lot of
a lot of sparklers here Hal is
independent
a lot of sparklers here we always like
to have sparklers in the chat
uh major Ojeda he's independent
independent night that's some content
for some other folks you know just like
we do content for other folks but truly
independent no one telling them what the
hell to say what the hell to do they're
gonna do it the way they want to do it
they're going to tell the truth
and if you don't like the truth well
fine
but the truth don't give a [__] about
your feelings it doesn't
and it won't never will
so we're truly independent here so I
appreciate all the support that you guys
give and I really want you to give
support uh to Gabe Sanchez and that
piece of content what was that we'll
watch it as soon as um Gabe makes his
way onto the show
but we always appreciate your guys's
support no matter where it's at rather
it's just subscribing and coming and
watching uh rather you're linking your
Amazon Prime account to the Twitch
account giving us support that way
that's a great way to support us without
having to spend spend a single extra
dime
uh rather you're watching us on Facebook
or you're you're participating over on
Discord and engaging with the community
over on Discord whether you're you're
whether you send venmo chats uh if you
want to get your message on the air
you know you can do that now too
just go to at the Tony Michaels on venmo
you can find us there uh let's see here
we've got one coming in here
um Robert sent one here if you're gonna
send also if you're gonna send a uh if
you're going to send a venmo chat what I
would suggest
but I was just put your YouTube handle
in there that way I can shout out your
YouTube or whatever whether you're on
Twitch or YouTube or you know wherever
you're wherever you want me to give this
shout out for
um this one is from Robert H I'm not
sure what handle he is or where he's at
but Robert H sent this venmo chat he
says Hunter Biden got to bang
prostitutes while smoking crack Mike was
omelets uh clearly the left is better at
handling their drugs too it is true it
is true I'm not gonna lie uh you know
they always they always make 100 Biden
sounds so cool don't they uh so this
this this venmo chat is from Robert H
again if you're gonna if you're going to
uh send a venmo chat if you want me to
give you the shout out with your uh
because I'm not gonna say your real full
name on here but if you want your if you
want your your handles out of that just
put your handle in the chat in in the
message that you send
and you'll get it on the screen here
with the venmo chat so thank you thank
you Robert for the uh the venmo chat and
and of course of course Hunter Biden's
cooler than Mike Lindell of course he is
Mike Lindell didn't take any pictures of
him having sex with prostitutes and
doing drugs so just there alone lets you
know that [__] Hunter Biden's better
partying than Mike Lindell
so thank you for the support again all
around no matter what kind of support it
is rather it's the venmo chat whether
you're subscribing here on YouTube
you're going over to the Discord page
you're following us on Facebook you link
your Twitch account to your Amazon
account whether you follow us on Twitter
you know what even if you're downloading
the audio version every single day on
Apple Spotify and Google we thank you
for your support we really do or if
you're on the up wires YouTube channel
you can go to the up wires and visit Jim
over there the moderator gym give him
some love
but the real the real way that you can
support like Dave Sanchez is go to what
was thatshow.com check out all the
extras there for his patreon page or go
to patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez or you
can go to thetonymichaels.com go to his
merch store get a pardon blanket while
you're there you might check out the
[__] em hats again it's [__] em hat week
and just use the promo code hat week 10
hat week 10. oh no excuse me hat week
now the last one was then hat week now
hat week now is the promo code and the
moderators will fix it there in the chat
so
now here's the um someone asking if the
there's a
the link for the venmo chat here's a
link for the venmo chat if you want to
do a venmo chat like Robert did there
you go there's the venmo chat and venmo
chat now
if you won't if you want to how's my mic
working out is my mic better I don't
know what happened it was probably just
YouTube glitching or some [__] it's
probably what it was where is where is
the guy with the last name Sanchez
uh let's see
uh whoops that's not what I wanted to
send him
oh goddamn autocorrect
let's go back to the um uh to the clips
here I've got a clip of uh Ben Shapiro I
want to show you uh he's he's bitching
about Donald Trump and what to expect
this is that whole Civil War [__] again
but here's Ben Shapiro's take on
Temple's uh Civil War in the comment
section one of the predictable results
of this is that people who have families
people who have a sense of Shame people
do not wish to see their lives at dug
through are simply going to stay away
from politics
that's the actual natural effect of all
of this is the best we'll not go into
politics anymore it'll be people who are
pretty much willing to Slug It Out in
court every single day because that's
what it's going to take from here on in
so I'm not sure the Democrats understand
the the
can of worms they have now opened
now they've been saying for a long time
that Donald Trump he's not normal it's
just not normal that he was President of
the United States and his behavior is
not normal and I won't be the first to
admit that I think that Donald Trump has
behaved in ways that are not typically
associated with the word presidential
but in terms of the behavior that he's
currently being indicted for
the notion that it is unprecedented for
a president of the United States to
engage in borderline criminal activity
in Rico violating ways that obviously is
not true
obviously obviously it is true you
[__] idiot and the reason why it is
true is because a grand jury
saw the evidence we're not talking about
we're not talking about one act here
this is not about one person doing one
thing in a grand jury going well looks
like it this is a grand conspiracy it's
a Ricoh charge and there's a reason why
it's a RICO charge is because it's a
criminal organization that decided to to
create to create an apparatus to
overturn an election in Georgia
there's 19 defendants there's 30
unindicted co-conspirators
that's 49 [__] that were that
they know of that were part of this
scheme
this criminal Enterprise to overturn an
election in Georgia
okay Ben
I don't get my wife wet Shapiro do you
understand maybe maybe maybe you should
get better at commentary maybe almost as
good as you are
getting your wife off which is not at
all
this is so ridiculous
this is what they're listening to folks
this is what they're hearing
you know what if Democrats want it boy
you got it there's not going to be
anyone that's good in politics there's
not anyone on your side that is good in
politics anyways and the reason why is
because of what you're saying but you
don't understand that it's projection
it's projection dude dude was how
[__] right was Ben Shapiro here Ben I
don't get my wife wet Shapiro how right
was he about the Barbie movie
hmm he said it was gonna flop if you go
woke you go broke there's no money in
feminism or the message of family
whatever the [__] it was
a billion dollars
over a billion dollars
is how much that movie sold
I don't I don't know if you know like
about movies
or about money
but that's a hell of an investment right
that's a great investment
they spent they probably spent four or
five hundred million on that thing to
make that I don't know exactly the
number making and marketing it and they
made a billion that's I don't know when
you consider doubling your money that's
pretty [__] good especially when
you're doubling your money in the
billions
I'm just saying
that it seems like the plastic doll that
Ben Shapiro was obsessed about for a
week
it made a lot of money
but listen this is all [__] and they
know it the problem is is these [__]
idiots have built their goddamn audience
full of Traders
right they're just Traders they're
people who hate democracy that's why
they got to go on and on on but this
isn't a democracy it's a republic well
what's a republic dummy tell me what a
republic is to find it
and they can't and they won't because
it's all [__] they don't Vince
Shapiro doesn't actually believe this
garbage listen I bet listen
and Gabe Sanchez can probably attest to
this because he did a what was that on
that I bet Ben Shapiro liked the movie
Barbie
I'm just saying but he can't Gabe he
can't like it like it their his audience
would have been like whoa whoa whoa
[__] you can't like that movie
but secretly deep down inside I met
mentioned here I love that movie
I I think I think there are uh there's a
part of me that
that considers Ben Shapiro liking Barbie
or or laughing you know obviously like
because Ben Shapiro's whole thing is he
he runs on on hate and he runs on like
hate baiting people to watch something
so in this footage of him saying like oh
well this is the you know this
this investigation has already tainted
the grand jury uh is coming after Donald
Trump and its political persecution and
you know this is uh
essentially saying Donald Trump did not
but like you know there's a clip that
came up of him in 2014 or whatever where
he's saying like yeah if you do commit a
crime then you should be held
accountable and if you're a president
who gets caught then maybe this will be
a deterrent for you to do that in the
future or uh to do that if you did
become president don't break the law do
not try to do anything because these are
the consequences
um and it shows you the transformation
that Ben Shapiro has made where he has
fully accepted the right wing extremists
and also he has accepted the
anti-Semitism even though he's like Whoa
man there's so many you know so much
anti-setting it's like anti-Semitism in
the Republican party or on the right
wing or whatever it might be and it's
like but you also
fan those flames you brought those
people to your content to watch and when
Donald Trump has uh you know a meal
around Thanksgiving with Nick Fuentes
and Kanye West and that's not both Nazis
Hitler loving anti-semites and you write
a uh a Twitter post that says maybe if
you don't want to be criticized for
having dinner with anti-semite blah blah
blah then don't have dinner with an
anti-semite blah blah blah but he's
unwilling to call out Trump specifically
for doing that and keeping it General
because he has to make sure that he
plays in this great area where he can
still get people you know as bad as as
terrible and vile as they are he needs
them right exactly he needs them in his
audience he needs them to keep listening
he needs them to keep paying him money
he can't abandon them now right this is
this is his cult right that he is built
he can't abandon him not for not for
anything especially the truth because
the truth of the matter is is that Ben
Shapiro knows that all these charges
against Trump aren't political in the
charges it's political crime that Trump
committed like yes yes I'll agree the
the [__] charges that Trump and the
cases that he's caught in DC and in
Georgia now yeah those are political
because he committed crimes
in politics
like literally he was trying to overturn
what do they call those things elections
for politicians
you [__] idiots yes it is political
yeah it's political he was [__]
trying to overturn elections that are
political but Ben Shapiro and people
like Charlie Kirk and Temple they know
better than this they're not that dumb
their audiences are their audiences are
dumber than dog [__] and that's the
reason why Ben Shapiro Tim pulled
Charlie Kirk and these others are
[__] trapped because like you said
they they need their dumb audience way
more way more than their dumb audience
needs them exactly they can go anywhere
they want to get the the [__] just
the vile [__] shoveled into their
[__] brains right and coming back to
the example of Barbie the the biggest
thing there and shows you exactly who
Ben Shapiro is
he never had to see the movie
he knew that when it comes push comes to
shove like he doesn't have to do
anything he doesn't want to do but he's
going to go because not only does he
want to go because he's actually
interested but two I mean also he has a
sister so I know for a fact that he grew
up in a household with Barbie dolls okay
and secondly the fact that he went and
then bitched and moaned about it he
never had to make a video about it he
never had to do anything but he knew
that if he did he would fan the Flames
of the extreme right and the people who
were upset I mean even Joe Rogan was
like I don't know why people are so
[__] pissed off I don't understand
why people are getting so like mad and
upset about this movie it was fun it was
bizarre it played on these tropes it
addressed this toxic masculinity men in
society women's role it was a fun weird
movie why are people freaking out if
you've got if you've got Joe Rogan
saying that and having some sense of
like logic and reasoning you've lost it
man
you've lost you've lost speaking who
else is losing in Iowa the GOP the GOP
is just getting their asses spanked in
Iowa Trump goes there for like 45
seconds the other day he got very tired
reports reports where he got very tired
after about an hour wow he was tired of
seeing people in Iowa is what he was he
doesn't care about Iowa no people are
like oh he came in for me only
he was just there to [__] Bash
the rest of the people who were in The
Running specifically Ron DeSantis
the reason he went he only showed him
before that there yeah I'm for that I'm
for that if there's a reason for Donald
Trump to go to Iowa is to ruin Ron
DeSantis career you know listen hey we
got to use the tools that are at
disposal and if we can use Trump as a
tool to destroy Ronda Santa's career
which it appears he has I don't know if
you know this but Ron DeSantis is
definitely not going to be president
anytime soon yeah like I just did he's
not he's not even not even in that same
universe as being president anytime soon
he's completely [__] they've all
hitched their wagon to Trump and they're
all going down well everything Trump
touches turns to liquid [__] so let's
see how the Iowa State Fair uh beard in
this new what was that from Gabe
with the last name Sanchez what was that
brand new right here hey everyone
welcome to what was that I'm Gabe
Sanchez Republican presidential
candidates are flocking to the Iowa
State Fair in an attempt to win over
voters and it's been an absolute clown
show here are some of the most insane
embarrassing and cringy moments from
candidates like Vivek ramaswamy Ron
DeSantis and of course Donald Trump
thank you
gotta love it pork chop from the
president but before we get into that
make sure to like this video subscribe
to this Channel and ring that
notification Bell so you never miss
another episode I personally want to
welcome everyone to the 2023 Iowa State
fail I mean uh Iowa State Fair now the
fair is a throwback to an earlier era of
politics more dominated by in-person
interactions rather than cable news
appearances however thanks to the
internet we get to witness all of these
interactions in real time and on repeat
like the vet Grandma Swami trying to do
a cringy live rendition of Eminem's Lose
Yourself
joking
joking now snap back to reality yes
please snap back to reality we're back
I'm getting secondhand embarrassments
not to mention that crowd is almost
motionless the vet is so detached from
reality that he doesn't realize that
some of these people don't even know who
Eminem is
[Music]
[Applause]
honestly Vivek has given me major
Kendall Roy Vibes right now breaking in
loot five star general your best salute
yo [__]
foreign
like literally he only performs this
song whenever possible
[Applause]
listen there's a
every time with the [__] commercials
every [__] time I don't know what to
tell you you blame blame YouTube man I
guess so
I attended Harvard he would perform as
his libertarian rapper Alter Ego javec a
personality that only emerges when Rama
Swami is outfitted entirely in Black
complete with a black Kangal hat but
somehow he still thinks it's a great
selling point of his campaign say my
name's Vivek it rhymes with cake it
ain't about thee it isn't about me it is
about Thee the United States is about
Liberty so Fox and Friends join us on
the trail we'll have some fun I'll see
you at the trail he just rhymed trail
with Trail no God
no God please no no no no
no you know what let's just establish a
few things here firstly maggot has some
of the worst rappers I've ever heard
yeah I'm looking at you fellatio blow
secondly just because you have a
microphone in your hand doesn't mean you
should use it to force cringy karaoke on
other people and thirdly as a performer
you should know how to read the room as
well as know how to interact in front of
your intended audience that last one is
something that Rhonda Santa struggles
with on a daily basis especially during
his presidential campaign one thing you
can know is okay well why is he
sorry that's my phone I don't know why
anyone's calling me they know I'm here
um
but you know I think part of the
question you know when you look at
people like you know why are they
running okay and let's just be honest
there's some people that are not running
really to be president right yeah why
are you running run because it sure
doesn't sound like people are all that
jazzed about your candidacy and our
state has never been better as a result
of our decision to keep Florida free
that response was more pathetic than Jeb
Bush begging people to clap that were
prepared to act in the National Security
interests of this country to get back in
the business of creating a more peaceful
world
police clap and it certainly didn't get
any better when Ron DeSantis decided to
wipe his snot on an Iowa Boater's hats
water okay
[Music]
DeSantis has been wiping his sweaty
snotty hands all over his failing
campaign yeah okay don't back
can someone get this guy a social
etiquette teacher wait hold on they
already did who Rudy Giuliani somehow
related to this but I do not know
whether good guys got it or bad guys got
it
now
[Music]
and taught me strong values every day
they never seem to show people like me
all right I think we can all agree that
we've had enough of Ron DeSantis just
like these two protesters in Iowa
or the person who paid for this Banner
to be flown over the Iowa State
Fairgrounds that said be likable Ron or
the Iowa voters who were not allowed to
ride the bumper cars because Ron in case
of the Santas had a shutdown for just
their family to use but no matter how
much Ron DeSantis tries to attract
voters with his pudding fingers
Republicans are just more interested in
being part of the cult that is Donald
Trump
[Music]
please
and as soon as he arrived his cult
members were waiting for him as well as
reporters many of which were wondering
if he plans to comply with a protective
order issued by judge chutkins
[Music]
by fighting and they put it out because
they can't win an election the Fairway
called election interference a Biden put
it up because he can't win the Fairway
he's way down on the ball yeah that's
not really his choice it's either comply
or his trial gets moved up but
apparently Trump thinks that the
protective order is optional so bold
strategy cotton let's see if it pays off
for him I'm pretty sure Trump's Attorney
John Laura really enjoys representing
him right now and then Trump was asked
if he intended to overturn the 2020
election President Trump did you intend
to overturn the 2020 election
the answer is yes but like all things
Trump does it miserably so now let's see
how Trump does that other parts of the
State Fair
[Applause]
2016.
for the 2024 within a three feet and
we're gonna make this man
there goes that darn magnomics again a
three-peat in a single state like Iowa
doesn't matter when you lose the popular
vote and the Electoral College in the
presidential election we very have to be
very careful she's so strong but she's
gonna have a baby in about two hours
this footage from rsbn is absolute
garbage and speaking of garbage
representative Greg stuby silhouette
main appearance with Trump
yesterday
articles against Joe Biden
those articles of impeachment include
abusive power bribery Hobbs act
extortion and honest Services fraud
obstruction of justice fraud and
financial involvement in drug and
prostitution well now that we've covered
Donald Trump's crimes where are
president bidens
seriously the projection and stupidity
from the Republican party never stops
especially when it comes from people
like representative Matt Gates Mr
President I cannot stand these people
that are destroying our country
they're opening our borders that are
weaponizing our federal law enforcement
against patriotic Americans who love
this nation as we should we are having a
great time at the bear we love standing
with you but we know that only through
Force do we make any change and it
corrupts town like Washington DC and so
to all my friends here in Iowa when you
see them come for this man know that
they are coming through our movement and
they are coming for all of us and as
hard as you see him work I need you to
work in 10 times harder 100 times harder
we're going to win we're going to watch
the nomination toward a state before
this country
leave it to the little piss ant Matt
gates to promote a normalized violence
while also trying to claim that coming
after Trump or breaking the law means
they're coming after Maga but as we all
know Republicans like Matt Gates talking
a big game but as soon as the going gets
tough they immediately play victim and
run away as quickly as possible kind of
like how quickly Trump got back on his
Mega funded plane after being in Iowa
governor is there any chance you take a
plea deal in Georgia
[Music]
Trump is right it is election
interference and he was the one doing it
in 2020
who can't even put two sentences
together but this is Joe Biden because
he can't win the election by himself he
can't win the election based on votes so
what they did is they got the Attorney
General to do it and then you see how
stupid they acted yesterday with the
appointment of the special counsel
call it special counsel and what a crazy
thing that was are you sick of having
issues with your webinars
another one another one [__] ads man
Trump is referring to David Wise being
appointed as special Counsel on the
hunter Biden investigation I find it
kind of funny though Trump attacks
president fighting for not being able to
put two cents together but Trump can't
even remember that back in 2017 he
appointed David Weiss as U.S attorney
for Delaware not only that but
Republicans like Marsha Blackburn are
now pissed off that David Weiss is
special counsel even though that's
literally what they asked for in
September 2022 34 Republican Senators
specifically requested David Wise the
extended special counsel protections and
authorities to conduct the hunter Biden
investigation but as we all know even if
Republicans get what they want they will
never be happy except when it comes to
supporting Donald Trump because as soon
as Trump starts to leave the tarmac this
sad interview with Brian Glennon a trump
supporter sums up his base perfectly
it's important that Outlets like myself
actually get out there and do this you
know I'm going to vote for the man with
the most impeachments and the most
indictments because guess what he knows
where all this corruption is now and
he's going to go in he's going to clean
up this is personal now I believe this
is personal to all of us that are voting
for him and it's so great to see okay I
like this supporter sums up Trump's face
perfectly and the way that he is treated
and Dishonored and the man comes back he
keeps fighting and fighting for this
country he's not been paid he donates
the money he comes back and he fights
again why he loves America and we matter
to him and he's not going to give up
he's not backing down and we aren't
either he he won that last three that
election before we went to bed and three
o'clock in the morning I woke up and I'm
like what happened the big dump and you
know people can say whatever but I'm
just telling you this man has been
anointed and this man is are he is our
way back I believe in our founding
fathers our Constitution and what's
happening in this country right now is
wrong in a travesty and we need him back
I couldn't have said that any better I
agree with 100 of what you just said
well that's all for me today thanks so
much for watching and feel free to
connect with me at I am Gabe Sanchez but
before I go I just want to remind
everyone that you can support this show
by you know for my patreon as a member
you'll get access to episodes before
they go public a live weekend show q and
A's and discounted merch just subscribe
go to patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez
foreign big dumps
I went to bed I want you're muted you're
muted you're muted Tony you're muted fix
your mic Tony you know how to work your
mic
you're muted again
yeah
that one was me that one yeah that was
you yeah I just loved I love anytime I I
watch that ending uh statement interview
from that woman she's like I went to bed
and then I woke up at three o'clock I
don't know why you woke up at three
o'clock but okay and then she was I woke
up at three o'clock and then what
happened a big dump
huge I mean well I mean hey sometimes I
wake up at three o'clock and there's a
huge dump you know what they call three
o'clock three o'clock is the witching
hour isn't yeah that's the hour where
like spooky [__] happens you get
possessed by the devil and all that
[__]
but the fact that she woke up at three
maybe she's possessed maybe she's a
little
cookie in the brain again man if you
have like chili the night before you
might wake up at three with a huge dump
I'm just saying it didn't have to be
election night it's not it's not a voter
dump no it's it's a it's a poop poop
yeah a poopy she woke up she woke up
with a poopy she's like Rumble in my
tummy what's this a poopy oh Trump lost
what a big dump
Mark Mark C son of a venmo chat here he
says yo Tony my bit to support an
independent media thank you mark C on
YouTube uh if you guys want to support
Independent Media you can do it several
different ways here on the Tony Michaels
podcast but again the way that I ask you
today to go support Independent Media is
go to patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez and
figure out exactly how you can support
Gabe with this what was that piece of
concrete I got another one I got another
one I filmed last night I got some
handcuffs in this one oh [__] yeah you
know wow are you putting this one on
PornHub then are you still putting on
you do I mean you know it there might be
like a censored version oh okay step on
Twitch are we at zero days is that does
that move the countertops we're back to
zero days go back to zero days yeah I'm
talking about let's do the rest of the
show like this you know Oh Daddy oh oh
wait wait is there some news here
someone's posting something in the um
in the Discord something about George
Santos that's your favorite guy oh what
happened to Georgie heads indict paid
fundraiser for George Santos for
allegedly but I don't know I'm not them
impersonating speaker McCarthy aide oh
that's the guy that's the guy that was
calling on behalf that was way back oh
so this is about a while ago no no this
is uh I'm trying to remember when he was
dead I remember when he was caught he
was revealed that he was calling and
pretending to be a a
a staff member yeah a fundraising did
this just happen or so is this is this
old news that I missed well it's not old
news that it happened it just happened
no they're saying it just happened no no
no what I'm saying is it's not sorry
it's old that it happened it's new news
okay that has been indicted let's get on
the indictment here I like George santor
Santos news he hadn't been in the news
for a while yeah I'm gonna be honest
here he's been a man who is paid to as a
campaign fundraiser for representative
George Santos was indicted in New York
on federal charges related to his
allegedly impersonated on top aide to
house Speaker Kevin McCarthy as he
solicited donations for Santos the
fundraiser Samuel meal meow mile
whatever yeah I'm not sure was charged
with four counts of wire fraud and one
count of aggravated identity theft in
the indictment issued in the U.S
District of eastern district
yeah sorry the U.S District Court for
the eastern district of New York right
that's where that's where Santos was
indicted to yeah the indictment comes
three months after this yeah it is the
eastern district yeah three months after
the New York Republican Santos himself
was criminally charged in the same court
by the U.S attorney's Office in Brooklyn
with fraud theft money laundering and
making false statements
yeah it was back in January because I
remember reading about this when they
were doing the like right before they
were doing the vote I think it was and
it was revealed that he was emailing and
calling a would-be donors claiming to be
Dan Meyer who is McCarthy's Chief of
Staff during the 2020 and 2022 election
Cycles well uh the congressman Dan
Goldman tweets out um this was just a
few minutes ago about 10 minutes ago he
said according to the Federal indictment
George Santos paid someone to
impersonate Kevin McCarthy's Chief of
Staff to raise money yet McCarthy
continues to protect Santos pathetic and
shameful and really that's kind of the
story Daniel Goldman's got it right like
the Santos Saga like he's done he's not
he's he's going to get primary and
whoever primaries him is going to
[__] get toasted in that District in
New York and the reason why is because
Republicans they they destroyed their
vote there with by backing Santos uh and
or whatever the hell his name is
um but it also looks like there's
another update on George Santos oh
really what the hell George Santos who I
just want to remind everyone has been
indicted on 13 criminal accounts that
include wire fraud money laundering
making false statements
he failed to meet the office wait wait
wait this this seems like a pattern with
these Republicans I'm not I'm not gonna
lie
but it turns out George Santos failed to
meet the August 13 deadline to file his
financial disclosure report according to
the New York Times
uh Georgia stands for his campaign this
is for his campaign for his campaign
yeah okay this is uh
so what's the consequences of failing to
do this because it feels like there's
not going to be any concert he received
a 90 hit or okay so uh he had already
received a 90-day extension from the
initial deadline which was May 15th
according to the report Federal
prosecutors say the New York Congressman
falsified the disclosures uh he filed as
a house candidate in 2020 in 2022. it's
crazy it's almost like maybe these
events are also connected because both
the guy that he hired did it in 2020 and
2022 and the fact that they were working
together would very much seem that they
were doing things in both of those uh
Congressional runs that they had
um the devilder organization and the
accounts and his bank accounts
misrepresented what his company and the
income that he had Santa's early this
year was accused of illegally using
campaign funds for personal expenses
including an apartment rental and for
submitting false information about both
the source of his campaign donations and
his campaign's expenses
uh last month obviously reported about
miles guo who's the Chinese billionaire
who's connected to Steve Bannon
all that stuff that's why you'll never
see that's why you'll never see George
Santos criticize miles guo if anything
he's going to be on Miles Grove's behalf
saying oh this was a this was unfair
persecution this is a Witch Hunt he
didn't do anything wrong
it it's not it's not because of that
it's because the money that's coming
into his pockets is coming from miles
12.
um
there's considerable speculation of
whether Miss Santos Financial disclosure
might shed light on the source of more
than the seven hundred thousand dollars
that he lent to his campaign which if
you remember when Steve Bannon had to go
to court for the build the wall scam
that he was doing
Matt Gates subbed in for him and had
George Santos on the show and Matt Gates
was like there's a lot of speculation
about where the money came from this and
that and then he said it was a personal
loan that he gave to his own campaign
and then we found out that that wasn't
the case we found out that there was
actual private donors who lent the money
and it wasn't George Santos who lent
himself
the seven hundred thousand dollars so
like every I mean you know we all know
this every chance the guy gets he's
going to lie it's going to be one lie to
get himself out of another lie and it's
going to be hard to keep track of Lies I
mean the guy forgot that he
said that he was a Volleyball Champion
MVP and had two knee surgeries because
of the wear and tear it turns out that
that person does this and had previously
worked together with George Santos but
that actually wasn't George Santos so he
likes to take people's stories and it's
like you know like I called him in one
of my what was that episodes I called
him the untalented Mr Santos because
that's what he is
Oh Boy George Santos you know who else
is kind of George Santos vibe to him
Andy Andy ogles you're into this guy in
Tennessee Andy ogles is he the mayor no
was the mayor he's a representative he's
a congressman right wasn't he the mayor
though yeah he might have been is it
either he had the photo with the guns I
why sure yeah because it was it was
after the shooting yeah he lies about
everything he lies about he's like
Tennessee's George Santos right well
this is a clip from Justin uh at
Tennessee the Tennessee holler and this
is Annie ogles trying to sneak out of
the back of this building and Justin's
just trying to ask him a question here
but you see this guy here this guy acts
really strange watch this exchange this
is how Republicans do it this is what
they mean by we're not a democracy we're
a republic this is the [__] they mean
move over there no I need you to move
over there
Andy
why do you think Trump is above the law
did you really go to Vandy Andy you know
fields
I don't know why you're acting like that
why are you running away from the people
Andy I'm in a public parking lot and
you're shadowing me
why do you think that's okay
you think that makes you tough what are
you doing he's gone just walking
are you guys serious right now help guys
no we're just walking guys what are you
guys doing have a great day
are you near me because you're talking
to me who are you what's your name
what's your name my name is Justin
why would you be
in my what
representative
you tried to you came damn close no yeah
I never I got you on camera okay that's
fine he's a congressman I'm asking him a
question he's my congressman
I'm allowed to do that this is America
do you remember what country this is I
know exactly what do you use it doesn't
seem like it because you're acting like
I'm doing something wrong by asking my
elected official question so I would
walk away now man
for the record Andy ogles this park
right here in this handicapped spot
the whole time
he always Jack Johnson walked in the
front he dodged his constituents but at
least he walked in the front and the
ogles and Oaky ogles slipped in the back
door and parked in a handicap's car
pinoki ogles
you're telling me the guy that lied
about his background also lied about
being handicapped to park in a space no
surely not no no no no surely not listen
you know I there seems to be a pattern
of my language this week including on
Monday that Republicans are cowards and
that's why I wanted to play this video
more than anything because they've got
to have a bunch of [__] thugged up
idiots and some people in the Discord
are asking uh what the what the lapel
pen is I bet we could figure out who
these [__] are based on that
lapel pin but I think the internet's
loose have already figured out who these
probably [__] tough guys who these
[__] tough guys are but this is how
they operate this is how they operate
they think they think they they are
Emperors they think they are above us
the voting class they don't they believe
they do not have to answer any questions
they do not they do not have to be held
accountable that's why they're all
[__] pissed off this week about the
charges in Georgia against Trump their
[__] managed dog [__] I mean Jesus
Christ they're pissed look at look at
Marjorie Taylor green here on Newsmax
let me see if I can get it to the
position in the video that I want yeah
she does someone's gonna have to tell
her that phony Willis is going after
rapist here but let's listen I also wait
hold on before you do this I haven't
watched this video I'm gonna assume I
could be wrong she's gonna say Fanny
Willis Fanny Fanny fonny I mean you know
no no no no no no no and I know why
they're doing this so Charlie Kirk
Lauren bobert
um who else there was a there were a
couple other correspondents that I
listened to on different right wing
shows lately but they're calling her
Fanny right because like it spills Fanny
it's not funny
Charlie Kirk got so upset he's like
Fanny Fanny after the news like the
indictment dropped they're like Fanny
and I was like dude you are very
triggered by a woman's name okay let me
tell you something let me tell you
something you want to know you don't
know you want to know the honest truth
about uh [__] someone's name up on
purpose it works right it works it
doesn't work it does it does but it's so
funny to see how upset they get it's one
thing to be like oh it's Fanny Wilson
but the way they say go Fanny
well Mary's right here it is a dog
whistle because what they're talking
about when they say Fanny is an ass is a
big ass and they're saying they're
saying black women have big fannies is
what they're saying that that's what it
is yeah I don't know if you know that
but that's the truth yeah that they're
using I mean they're trying to do
they're trying to make fun of the name
in terms of like oh there's a black
Sunday name it should be Fanny and I'm
like
that's all you guys have that's all you
guys have you literally have that and
then is that or is that a real full name
first name or is it short for something
uh I don't know if it is I mean look it
up look it up
um well let's watch let's watch uh
Marjorie Taylor green tell us why uh the
D.A the elected D.A in Fulton County is
oh man yeah that's her that's her full
name
Fanny uh funny oh yeah sorry sorry phony
typha tafa yeah I don't know it's uh
t-a-i-f-a Willis but that's her full
name
um also
uh someone points out that fanny has two
ends in it
Fannie Mae Freddie Mac Oh Freddie Mac
Fannie Mae yeah yeah yeah
but anyways let's speak in a speaking at
[__]
let's go let's go to this [__] I
think that the DA's all seem to share an
ideology here politically I mean you've
got uh Willis's family was made up of
marxist black panthers uh you've got
Alvin Bragg obviously uh buys into the
same kind of ideology the way that he's
uh destroying this city he doesn't want
to throw anybody in prison for for
committing crime uh they all share this
really just devastating ideology that is
so it's almost like he's talking about
something else that they shared is there
something else that's similar of the
Manhattan D.A and the The Fulton County
D is there something similar between
them I don't know I mean it's a
Maybe
it could be
that they're all black uh well you know
Donald Trump actually used a hard r
in the um in the Tweet the other day
riggers he wanted he wanted he wanted to
say it yeah right he wanted to say it
yeah he was calling he was calling those
prosecutors
with a hard R riggers two hard R's if
you wanna know that on the street but
let's see let's see what uh Marge hook
foot three toes Petty Eddie green has to
say devastating for this country uh they
unite around that and then they try and
take down somebody that's somebody like
this somebody like former president
trump it kind of makes sense
that's right Rob and people everywhere
are terrified of this government uh this
is something that we expect in third
world countries that we expect in
communist regimes but this is what we're
seeing in America today you know Rob I
live in a rural District this is where
people really want a dollar 75 gas back
they do not like the Biden policies a
lot of people on fixed incomes like
senior citizens uh single moms just good
working people are going month to month
with their paychecks and maxing out
their credit cards with high inflation
High grocery bills High electricity
bills and high gas bills but they're
watching the Biden regime actually try
to arrest president Trump lock him up in
jail for the rest of his life which is a
death sentence and then go after his
supporters across the state it's it's
something that um it's still shocking I
can't even okay so first off these are
these are these are um County
Prosecutors you see they're elected by
the people in the County and here's what
happens Marge I want to describe you I
don't you clearly do not watch enough
murder dramas or like murder docu-series
here's what happens when you commit a
crime in a jurisdiction
you are prosecuted for that crime that
you committed in that jurisdiction in
that jurisdiction so yeah I don't get
that though the issue is it makes too
much sense it's almost no no Tony just
because you commit a crime in one spot
doesn't mean that you have to pay for
that crime in that one spot okay right
right we're making stuff up okay
me and my facts right me and my facts
she's still she's still to this day
maybe this is why she doesn't understand
why all the j6 defendants are in the
Washington DC in the jail in DC she
didn't understand that she didn't get
why they're because they committed crime
there dummy like they literally
expect do you expect Margaret Taylor
green well to understand that though
well not after what she says here about
how how how the DEA down in Fulton
County should do her job let's listen I
believe it happened yesterday yeah but I
want to tell you something about Atlanta
Robin it's really important for people
to know Atlanta has some of the highest
crime in the country murder rape
carjacking and the state of Georgia is
one of the worst states in the country
for child sex trafficking Jima last week
with Homeland actually told me that
every single month in the state of
Georgia every month men will buy a child
for sex on average 7 200 times Bonnie
Willis should be going after child sex
predators and traffickers Bonnie Willis
should be going after murderers rapists
rapists she says she should be going
after rapist is anyone going to tell her
that um Bonnie Willis
actually this week brought Rico charges
against a known rapist I don't know if
she knows that
like it's an he's a known rapist well I
I mean it's proven in court
a jury of his peers has said that he
raped e Gene Carroll
so he's a rapist so she's I I think
Marjorie Taylor's a Green's right here
and D.A Willis should go after that
rapist she she should and she is I think
I think it's just like I just like I
said in the what was that you know
stewby's like I or I filed articles of
impeachment against Joe Biden here are
the Articles and it's fraud and it's
prostitution and it's this and that it's
like all right sounds great you just
named all the crimes for Donald Trump
right
if you do in fact have you know things
that are can you can prove that that Joe
Biden or any of these other Democrats
have done please bring them forward and
that seems to be the narrative we have
Stephen Miller Charlie Kirk
um I'm trying to remember who else was
doing it but there were a bunch of other
Republicans who are trying to use the
narrative that we talked about yesterday
which was
can a D.A or an attorney general
just go and indict
Biden or these other Democrats and I go
okay good great great great go do it you
should do it 100 and I said that
yesterday on the charges I quote tweeted
uh Stephen Miller because he was like
can we get a D.A to go after it and I
was like go for it go for it I I hope
that you do and then people were like
wait are you serious what do you mean by
this and I was like because they have
nothing right I want them to try because
they're gonna fail because no no even or
any even a right-wing district attorney
or or
attorney general would never touch that
without actual proof and doing the due
diligence of investigating well they
technically can't like they can't go to
court without evidence they can't go
into court and be like well we're filing
charges why well because the grand jury
wouldn't convict because we are wouldn't
indict because we didn't have evidence
so I'm just bringing charges what what's
your charges well I'm charging them with
bribery well where what what bribe well
I don't know I just feel like that they
committed bribery so I'm going to file a
charges the judge is going to tell them
to [__] off yeah
Rudy Giuliani and now Rudy Giuliani is
getting charged with Rico and he also
from what I understand is in not only
significant legal Peril but he's also
got significant financial apparel
because he spent so much of his own
[__] money defending Trump and also
not getting paid oh that's great that's
fantastic so even in the conspiracy
where they're trying to overturn the
government Rudy Giuliani isn't getting
paid for this league
I will say this no one no single person
of the 18 defendants that are with Trump
are going to get any protection legally
from him because the first person on the
list the first person who sold her soul
to to to
to collect the drippings off of Rudy
Giuliani and ride the coattails of
Donald Trump
is Jenna Ellis and Jenna Ellis now has
to have a give send go campaign that was
started by her lawyer that's
representing her because she doesn't
have the money or supposedly doesn't
have the money to pay for it and also
Donald Trump's pack is not paying her
legal you know why you know why Donald
Trump's pack is not paying her legal
bills
she's a DeSantis supporter exactly we've
heard her in those spaces oh yeah she's
like oh Rhonda Santa is not so bad this
and that loyalty is what buys you uh
protection but even if you were loyal to
Donald Trump you still wouldn't get
money from the pack to cover your legal
bills so now these people have to go out
and beg for money the very people who
say socialism is bad and uh government
social programs are the devil's work and
whatever else they might say but now you
know like true Hypocrites at the
Republican party they are out there
begging please may I have another
begging for money hoping that someone
they can grift into giving them and pay
for their legal expenses because Donald
Trump was like nope nah I already
grifted all these guys I already built
you all I'm not giving you any of the
money that these dumbasses gave me
because you didn't say that you like me
you didn't say that you don't like
Rhonda the santis you made it very clear
that you're not loyal to me and because
of that you can go [__] yourself
well the other thing about Jen Alice
Jenna listen
if you if I don't know if you know this
but like if you cannot afford an
attorney we'll get one for you because
you're you're entitled to a legal
offense so in this country like you
literally you can have a public defender
so the good thing good sent or go give
send a go doesn't work out for you I'll
probably just gonna be there to help you
and I I have to say I really love all
these people going to give send go
because we know and we've talked with
with uh uh Hi-Fi about this
is gifts and go is used on uh amongst
right wing extremists
you know whether it's money laundering
or trying to use those those sources of
income we saw during the the TR the uh
the freedom Convoy and the truckers who
are trying to uh protest and boycott and
shut the economy down by not driving
their trucks and doing their deliveries
yeah we got a video on it that we're
playing exactly and so in yeah and in
that you know gifts and go is the number
one culprit there they're the ones that
are allowing these suspicious payments
happening from a non-real people
they're coming from accounts that the
the kind of uh
uh the way that Hi-Fi said it was
the payments that were coming through
was were so suspicious because these
people the there were multiple emails
that were being reused again and again
and again and the people didn't link up
and the people that use the emails with
the credit cards weren't in the same
location so there's a lot of like sus
things that are happening in Gibson go
the same same place that
um Ellen Wood used and uh Kyle
Rittenhouse used all of these people
that are right wing extremists they
always go to gifts and go and all the
suspicious activity is all in give send
go should we start a Gibson go I don't
know maybe we should start one
maybe we'll see maybe we get some shady
Russians to give us some money I'm just
saying I watched but I I watched some
stuff on Rudy Giuliani last night and I
gotta what was that coming out but he
was like oh I'm being accused of been
doing I'm being charged with Rico I was
the first one want to do that like he
invented [__] Rico yeah well well
Rudy Rudy listen don't do the crime if
you don't want to do the time yeah and
speaking of talking about crime and
nonsense you know Rudy Giuliani talks
nonsense all the time like the guy used
to be like a United States Attorney
southern district of New York and he did
he brought a lot of Rico charges against
like Monsters and stuff but now you
can't even make sense of anything he
says I don't know if he's too drunk or
he just drank away all his brain cells
but uh log Foghorn Leghorn here uh
Senator not real accent by the way right
uh John Kennedy listen to some of this
gobbledygook on the Hugh Hewitt Show
talking about the the Trump indictments
and [__] this is wild stuff how does
anyone take this [__] seriously
listen to this it's president Trump has
been indicted four times in the last
five months
yes it's it's for real politically no it
is real it is it is real
um I gotta say Hugh Hewitt gets some of
the best weirdest deranged interviews
I've ever seen most of them are on the
phone and I really after you watch this
you John Kennedy should have done this
on the phone
he really should have done this one by
the phone uh here but he I mean what
Trump does Trump never goes live on the
webcam he always calls in right which is
always hilarious to to listen to because
you're like well I wonder what he's
doing at the same time
well let's let's continue to listen to
the the weird stuff that I love that
snapshot though
I get the best freeze frames let's go
you know politically it's
it's sort of like a zombie apocalypse I
don't
know how is this I mean when I heard
this I was like does he mean that Trump
supporters are gonna be the Zombie
Apocalypse because how else is this
gonna go what do you what do you mean I
mean think about it zombie what is he
talking about he's saying
I don't know I was so confused this
morning I'm like the closest thing to
design zombie apocalypse in this country
that we've seen in recent history is
January 6 like literally they were
climbing the walls and [__] they were it
was yeah it was like uh is that what
it's saying I don't know I mean like I
mean Jan six was kind of like World War
Z but just not as successful in there
right right right well and they had they
had fewer teeth uh at January 6th than
than World War Z but I mean your teeth I
haven't seen teeth on him yet
let's let's keep listening to the the
guy who's talking about zombies I don't
know I mean we're not talking about a
doordash driver here uh he's a former
president of the United States and he is
a current active candidate for president
of the United States
[__] on doordash drivers
why do Republicans always do this when
they're like when they're like he's the
president of the United States he ain't
no goddamn dorm Dash driver like what
why are you always always oh I know why
they [__] on average Americans because
they don't give a [__] about average
Americans and this only proves that
Senator Kennedy wants Donald Trump to
get special treatment
he thinks Donald Trump is above it all
and he's an elite way better than those
doordash drivers out there double star
Dash drivers I swear it's like a zombie
apocalypse hold on I gotta put my gotta
put my teeth back in just gonna get him
out of the glass here hold on
a zombie apocalypse a zombie zombie
apocalypse doordash drivers let's see
what else this idiot comes up with
running against
a party
um
whose four prosecutors have indicted him
and regardless of what you think about
President Trump
um this is unprecedented
um it is it is really right like we
never had a president ever in the
history of our country try to overthrow
an election we've never had that yet
yeah it is crazy it's crazy it's totally
impressive there are moments there were
moments when he reminds me of Herbert
from Family Guy he's like Ashley
so I went down to the basement
and I got some got some zombies got some
zombie ice cream and I went back
upstairs got my newspaper I just it just
he just makes me think of Herbert I'm
just saying you know oh my God
he didn't break it he didn't break the
law he just he did it was completely
instant
if you want to really cast our political
system I mean this is the sort of thing
that happens
[Laughter]
jackpots is our jackpot is uh 387
chickens on a goat
now he's talking about a Powerball
jackpot what the [__] is this guy
talking about
I can't I can't I [__] can't we don't
do that in America now having said that
this was the first time but I can assure
you it won't be the last there are
thousands of prosecutors out there in
America Republican and Democrats
and now that the class has been broken
what that means
oh my God yes oh man I'm [__] red
from like I had no idea that clip was
gonna do that but uh it certainly did
[Music]
you know gotta go to the capital and he
got a phone to shop Donald Trump from
not man president you got to make them a
president
it's just like just [__] put the
teeth back in man
see what's going on here yes is there
for zombies they never ghosts and they
were goblins
and I saw them in the middle of the
nights when I woke up at three in the
morning after the election and I saw a
big dump
well there's big time John Kennedy oh my
God oh my God I have people people oh
wow these people are so [__] dumb
doordash Choppers and [__] ghosts and
zombies and man I don't know
I don't know if you took too little
medication or too much medication but
John Kennedy needs to get that regulated
now
holy [__] what an end to the show
[Music]
I got a side Tony that was that was a
great show that was a wonderful show it
it certainly was certainly [__] was
Kennedy and I love the Tony Michaels
podcast I I approve this message
I'm down candy and I approve this
message
uh now the audience is like uh these two
[__] Chuckles they're just they're
just having fun Kennedy
and this show is the best Hugh Hewitt
[__] you
oh thank you thank you uh Senator John
Kennedy uh for your absolute nonsense
and your word salad this morning your
Southern word salad your fake Southern
word salad this morning it was fantastic
I don't know how he went from zombies to
doordash to Powerball where you win
chickens I'm not sure exactly I don't
know how that I don't know what that has
I don't know what the [__] that has to
do with Trump or his legal issues but
apparently I don't know if he's taken
too little medication or too much but he
needs to get an underfucking control he
does he does he does need to get it
under control and I have to get this
show under control because we're over
time we're over time we'll be back
tomorrow you gotta subscribe that way
you don't miss a single episode Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
two full hours maybe the last 15 minutes
would just be us cackling into the
microphone because John Kennedy is
talking about zombies and Powerball and
doordash and comparing it to Donald
Trump I don't know and then you got
Santa the guy with the last name Sanchez
over here yeah with the last name
Sanchez yeah
Discord can't handle it over there if
you guys want to keep in the chat it's
where the party never stops go go join
the Discord let me put the uh the link
in the chat right now and you know every
time I uh every time I put this link in
the chat there's like 30 people that go
over so let me put it in here [__]
yeah so go over the chat never snaps to
the Discord it's in the chat now
also follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels follow us on Twitch you can
watch us over there twitch.tv slash the
Tony Michaels also download every single
episode on Apple's Spotify Google in the
afternoon once my dumb ass gets it all
edited up and posted over there once I
get off my ass and get it done right Rob
H says Gabe pimp you're setting the
Kennedy voice all right hold on do it
that's it hi everyone come to what was
that what was that show.com or
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez and that's
where you can become a patron and join
And subscribe my join so you can join my
community my name is John Kennedy and I
approve this message
okay Sanchez's patreon support him as an
independent crater he's a great guy and
he's also funny he's definitely not
doing this for right now
oh so go to patreon.com I am Gabe
zenches if you want more content like
that you got to go over there and
support Independent Media uh what a
great what was that and what a great uh
and into the show I tell you that was
nice we're gonna do um on Roundtable
democracy on my patreon page we're gonna
change the name of the workshops I've
decided we're gonna change the name of
we're gonna call them 10 minute tips 10
minute tips 10 minute tips of democracy
that sounds nice
well listen when you're doing democracy
you just want the what do you want what
do you want John just the what you just
want the zombies no the tip
[Laughter]
10 10 minute tips of democracy zombies
tips we're gonna do one and
who won tomorrow we're gonna do a 10
minute tip tomorrow uh on a on a piece
of
of media that on how to Pivot and attack
that's right how to Pivot and attack
when you're talking to chuckleheads like
John Kennedy so when you're talking to
chuckleheads like John Kennedy this
piece of information is going to teach
you how to Pivot and attack we're gonna
do a 10 minute tip tomorrow after the
show so don't forget to go to
patreon.com the Tony Michaels while
you're on their visit games page
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez we'll talk
more about the 10 minute tip putting
just the tip in for democracy
just tip just a tip we'll talk more
about that 10 minute tip on Roundtable
democracy tomorrow until then tomorrow
same time same place what do you say
John Kennedy Surf Shop [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them
foreign
[Music]
the Donald called Down to Georgia
because he was looking for some votes to
steal he was in a bind because he was
way behind and he was all up in his
fields and he told that attorney general
there's no way that I lost it's just
like on TV You're The Apprentice I'm the
boss and then he told that state of
Georgia you just find me what I need so
nothing bad comes for you I'm Trump I
don't concede so funny gather up your
jurors evidence and spies cause Hills
broke loose in Georgia and the Donald
deals in lies and if we when we lock him
up and throw away the key but if we lose
the fuhrer gets set free
then his trial came along and let him
plead his case and he knew he had that
jury beat you could see it on his face
and that prosecutor looked at him and
said you're pretty goddamn dumb just sit
back in that chair right there let me
show you how it's done so Donnie you
should a run boy run
because now you're in the house where
your jail time comes you should have
stayed out there paying off hoes now
you're headed to the house where the
convicts go and when that trial was over
Donnie knew that he had been beat and
then bailiffs come along and they Rose
into his seat and they slapped them
cuffs around his wrist and they led him
to the pin it's America you son of a
[__] we're the best there's ever been
so Donnie you should run boy run because
now you're in the house where your jail
time comes
you should have stayed out there paying
off hoes now you're headed to the house
where the convicts go
inmate Trump 2024.